les conditions météos bouchon de retour
mais la france sur route et sur rail a
mieux circulé dimanche météo france
moins pessimistes qu annoncé pour les
jours qui viennent un revenu substantiel
ça marcherait jeudi calme précaire à
banvit après l'opération de représailles
française contre les soldats mutins
celle ci a fait au moins dix morts la
criminalité en baisse dans les grandes
villes américaines pour la cinquième
année consécutive
en 1996 on a enregistré moins de mille
meurtres à new york du mieux dans le
pire idée noire
le dessinateur franquin père de gaston
lagaffe est mort il avait 72 ans madame
monsieur bonsoir le sud et le centre de
la france restent les secteurs les plus
touchés par les intempéries et le froid
la neige et le verglas continuent de
rendre difficile la circulation dans la
région rhône alpes mais dans l'ensemble
les retours de vacances ont pu se passer
et la tendance a été ce dimanche à
l'amélioration reportage à châteauroux
puis des visseyrias jean-paul miotto il
devait se rendre en angleterre sans
voyage s'est arrêté au bord de la
nationale
et d'argenton sur creuse il faudra une
grue pour le sortir de là je me suis
arrêté est bon je passe deux minutes
après j'étais en train de préparer mon
réveil pour le matin le j'ai senti un
petit mouvement du véhicule et
l'ensemble routier a glissé le terrain
ce routier l'une des innombrables
victimes du verglas et de la neige qui
depuis deux jours paralysent le centre
de la france les 120 kilomètres qui
séparent limoges de châteauroux en
témoigne encore hier les vacanciers qui
remontait du sud ouest sont restés
bloqués sous la neige tenter d'aller sur
sur bourges
mais bon pour faire 20 km il nous a
fallu désert dans la haute vienne et
dans l'indre les automobilistes en
perdition ont pu se réfugier dans des
centres d'hébergement d'urgence comme
ici dans ce lycée de château ce matin au
moment de repartir
beaucoup se plaignaient de l'action des
services de l'équipement sur la
nationale 20 on a vu les sableuses à 5
heures de l'après midi c'est trouve
qu'on a mise en militant pour venir des
accusations que réfute la dde qui
travaillent sur cette nationale 24
heures sur 24
les trois saleuses qui tourne d'ailleurs
tout le pays où quelqu'un de sûr c'est à
dire depuis vendredi les serrures et
camions au premier inter on les atteint
pas parce qu'on sait pas même si pour
démarrer cette après midi la situation
est redevenue normale entre limoges et
châteauroux
les principales routes sont dégagées
mais on n'oubliera pas ce terrible
week-end
dans les alpes-maritimes une opération
d'évacuation a dû être organisé pour une
cinquantaine de touristes bloqués par la
neige dans un village du haut pays
niçois allemand nicosie jean-françois du
rejet dans l'histoire d'un village
indiscutablement il y a des journées
particulières estaing dans les alpes du
sud se souviendra de ce 5 janvier à 10
heures du matin
cinquante personnes sont encore bloquées
dans ce hameau à 1800 mètres d'altitude
à la guinguette où vivent les personnes
tu sais pas plus que les gens du sac
il faut se résoudre à abandonner les
voitures la route coupée en trois
endroits par des avalanches est
impraticable et si le téléphone
fonctionne encore par miracle
l'électricité elle est complètement
coupée oui les hauteurs de nice qui a eu
les cumuler tout puisqu'on voit mais
plus la cheminée on voit plus rien il y
avait des gens qui étaient dessous dans
le chalet qui sont partis qui vont
partir de soigner son père et puis bon
ben maintenant on attend dehors avoir
l'électricité un petit peu pour remettre
tout en place pour autant ici personne
ne panique la solidarité n'est pas un
vain mot destin est fermé et totalement
en autarcie nous rapatrions tous sur la
place destin odiah l'hôtel où tout le
monde peut se retrouver se rassemblent
et vient aux nouvelles et c'est très
très chaleureux entre autres les
techniciens d'edf ont déposé la ligne
pour dégager la place suffisante
un hélicoptère au même moment à 60
kilomètres de là un puma de l'armée de
terre a été réquisitionnée il qu'on voit
un groupe électrogène d'urgence une
évacuation des personnes les moins
sportives est même prévue en hélicoptère
vers 13h mais il n'y aura pas de la
place pour tout le monde alors
spontanément un groupe de 25 personnes a
accepté de tenter la descente en
raquettes
une heure trente de parcours dans trois
mètre de poudreuse pour rejoindre en
trône et la première route dégagée un
peu la trouille et à sion à un moment
mais bon finalement ça s'est bien passé
wen devait faire une rando ce matin
comme ça elle est faite c'est cool les
secours se présente sous la forme d'
engin de l'équipement qui luttent pour
désenclaver la vallée après plusieurs
journées de travail sans relâche s'ils
ne sont plus qu'à 4 kilomètres à
l'avalanche déclencher les avalanches et
déclenché à quatre couloirs on pense
sous 48 heures 72 heures au pire si la
météo est favorable pour nous ce soir ne
reste plus à estaing que les gens du cru
les autres seront demain au bureau ou au
lycée avec une aventure hors du commun a
raconté dans le sud-ouest ce dimanche
était au répit notamment sur la
nationale 10 françois prive philippe
ritaine le dégel et des grands axes
devenu à nouveau praticable dans le sud
ouest du pays
la nationale 10 entre angoulême et
poitiers aujourd'hui sur le bas côté des
véhicules immobilisés
la plupart depuis plus de 24 heures et
parfois ça bouchonne encore un peu pour
77 km on a mis deux heures donc là on
est arrivé là donc angoulême on pensait
que ça vaudrait que ça roulait bien
qu'il avoue vient d'être arrêté par leur
part un accident semble-t-il
voilà la font del moral quelques chutes
de neige et du brouillard mais comme la
chaussée est régulièrement dégagé on
circule à vitesse normale c'est à ruffec
au sud de poitiers que l'on a accueilli
plus de 300 personnes bloquées sur la
route peuvent inciter à aller à
l'essentiel et laisser partir c'est que
pour ce soir les annonces encore du
froid et donc du verglas alors les
derniers la voyait son ancien sur le
départ nous a dit que ça roulait bien
donc voilà on envisage de rentrer à la
maison
on va essayer de rentrer à bordeaux
avait quand même avant la nuit
on va essayer en espérant d'arriver à
bordeaux
encore deux bonnes heures de trajet
avant d'atteindre bordeaux où la
température a frôlé les 9 degrés cet
après midi
actuellement en charente seuls quelques
routes départementales restent
difficilement praticables
conséquence des intempéries la rentrée
scolaire est reportée à mardi
dans l'indre la drôme et la vienne dans
l'allier la haute garonne et le gers est
également dans les pays de loire le
ramassage scolaire ne sera pas assuré
lundi par ailleurs trente et une
communes des pyrénées atlantiques et des
landes reste privée de téléphone cela
dit si dans les pyrénées la météo était
plus clémente les stations blocs qui ont
été dégagés et la descente des
vacanciers a pu s'effectuer dans des
conditions relativement correct
christophe la rocca xavier arias ironie
c'était le grand beau temps aujourd'hui
dans les pyrénées mais ils n'étaient
qu'une poignée en profiter la majorité
des vacanciers bloqués depuis 24 heures
dans les stations des pyrénées
occidentales a préféré partir dès le
matin à gourette
ils étaient plusieurs centaines à
attendre dès 8h de pouvoir partir
quelques kilomètres en contrebas une
commission de sécurité inspectent les
flancs de la montagne
le temps est heureux d'où le risque
d'avalanche maximum s'est chargé d hier
mais séduit ça va charger comme il fait
froid je pense pas qu'on ait des
découler aujourd'hui les risques donc on
va parce qu'on a quand même 5 à 6000
personnes qui veulent partir maintenant
à 9h30 le signal de départ est donné
avec 24 heures de retard chacun se
prépare à prendre la route plutôt dans
la bonne humeur philosophie complètement
comment ça s'est passé hier soir et
dormir entrer dans la location qu'on
avait puisque tu veux pas partir nos
successeurs ne pouvait fournir
on est à gagner on peut dire une journée
une soirée de plus mais je préfère le
passé chez moi
les enfants était inquiet pour l'école
non pas du tout ils ont profité de la
neige au maximum si tout s'est
finalement bien passé c'est que la
station et les commerçants ont su jouer
fair play les hôteliers ont offert la
nuit d'hôtel les agences de location la
nuit dans les meubles et les remontées
mécaniques ont offert les remontées
mécaniques et hier et je crois que les
commerçants ont tous avaient tous le
sourire ce soir ou descendez même
s'enchaînent de la plupart des stations
en priant très fort pour ne pas trouver
de gros bouchon plus loin
l'hiver quand il est fantasque comme
cette année compliquer l'exercice de
certains métiers ainsi en va-t-il de ce
médecin installé dans les pyrénées dans
la vallée de campan
cela fait dix ans qu'il n'avait pas eu
autant de difficultés à faire ces
visites jacques cardoze france veille
difficile de ne pas en tenir compte dans
la vallée de campan ou plus généralement
dans les pyrénées il est des métiers où
la météo dicte sa loi
alors ne lui dites surtout pas que le
rôle du médecin de montagne se limite
aux soins surtout par ces temps
d'enneigement inhabituel bernard teper
ou de la nourriture n'arrive pas souvent
parce que
les gens sont habitués en toujours les
provisions m'avait c'est arrivé si vous
n'êtes pas seulement un médecin
on n'est jamais à montagne seulement
mais le serbe est honnête
un habitant du pays avec la solidarité
pays est un plus ainsi depuis 26 ans
jean-yves selma parcourt les routes
pyrénéennes à bord de son 4 4 sacoche et
médicaments à la main il rend visite aux
habitants de la région
gaston vie à 1000 mètres d'altitude dans
cette petite grange et là il se fait
reboot un genou il a cette fois quant à
ces rendez-vous il les prend parfois sur
la route
au hasard des rencontres consulter à
domicile est devenu difficile depuis le
début de la vague de froid
de mémoire de médecins l'enneigement
n'avait pas été aussi important depuis
mais comme ce médecin de montagne aime à
le répéter
pas question de refuser les
consultations même s'il faut parfois
emprunté des chemins difficiles
dans le pire des cas il faudra chausser
les skis la sncf a amélioré toute la
journée ces dessertes le tgv circulent à
nouveau sur le sud ouest et les retours
des alpes prioritaires ont été assurés
l'une de nos équipes a emprunté un
lyon-paris cet après-midi en portage
benoît gadret philippe évêques
ils étaient partis pour des vacances au
soleil et c'est la neige qui a perturbé
leur séjour sur lequel la famille prieto
attend une nouvelle fois ils ont quitté
cannes ce matin 6 heures pour rejoindre
paris via lyon lyon ou leur tgb a pris
du retard
encore des ennuis et puisque on affiche
quart d'heure de retard si si tout va
bien je pense pour l'europe d'être plus
décidément les temps sont durs à la sncf
pour les usagers comme pour les agents
du rail
mais on sera discuté toute la journée
là on est là pour ça lui prenait avec le
sourire oui il faut avec 25 minutes de
retard le tgv entre enfin en garde
25 minutes ce n'est finalement rien pour
notre famille qui devait rejoindre paris
vendredi
mais faute de train les premiers taux
ont dû patienter deux jours tant que ce
soit toujours retardé vu que les clo
conditions climatiques et qui nous avait
dit dès lundi le gel revenait
on a eu peur ce soit encore retardé et
le prix du retour est élevé 700 francs
de supplément pour la première classe 40
secondes
les rames sont bondés le trafic est
restreint c'est un peu la course au tgv
normalement je vais à saint malo j'ai
une préférence pour n avait 15 ans
c'est raté c'est raté donc je pense que
je vais passer la lumière
à paris la sncf manque de trains de
nombreux tgv bloqués dans les
intempéries doivent être révisées du
coup les ram disponible tourne à plein
régime cela se voit elles sont à peine
nettoyer en faire arriver tout va bien
pour notre famille accueillis par des
proches
car pour d'autres voyageurs une nouvelle
fois la tente ne fait que commencer
c'est demain après midi au mieux que le
trafic sncf devrait retrouver la normale
l'amélioration d'aujourd'hui est à
tempérer par des retards systématiques
en direct avec nous de lyon la part-dieu
maryse burgot vous confirmez maristes
oui alors comme vous le voyez la gare de
lyon part dieu qui était bondé tout
l'après midi s'est progressivement vidé
la preuve que même si les trains avaient
aujourd'hui beaucoup de retard et bien
ils sont finalement partis les gens
continuent ans quand même à se plaindre
toute la journée d'un certain manque
d'information alors côté sncf on dit
aujourd'hui avoir transporté sept cent
mille personnes c'est beaucoup c'est
inhabituel même en cette journée de
retour des vacances alors les retours
des stations de sports d'hiver se sont
relativement bien passé trafic normal en
provenance des alpes et de la savoie ici
à partir de lyon le trafic a été rétabli
maintenant à 75% en fait l'abcès de
fixation c'est ce soir toujours le sud
ouest de la france
le trafic tgv n'est pas cette heure
toujours pas totalement rétabli entre
bordeaux et poitiers cela devrait être
fait demain en début d'après-midi alors
une bonne nouvelle quand même pour les
appeler qui font leur service militaire
dans l'est de la france
ils vont avoir un répit de 48 heures
pour rejoindre leur base puisqu'un
certain nombre de train de
permissionnaires ont été affectés aux
retours des vacanciers voilà il y en a
pour qui le mauvais temps n'a pas été
une si mauvaise affaire
merci maryse burgot pour les jours qui
viennent la météo est moins pessimiste
que ces dernières 48 heures il ya des
chances de redoux substantielles en
milieu de semaine jean-claude allanic
eric georgeault un froid de canard
eux ils en ont l'habitude les français
qui grelotte depuis plus de deux
semaines beaucoup moins alors le redoux
relatif de ce week-end annonce-t-il la
fin de cette vague de froid
réponse mitigée des spécialistes de
météo france
sa semaine mais trouvait semaine en fait
donc on a eu un retour ce week-end et
vous attendra de bus froid donc surtout
dans la nuit de lundi à mardi
du froid un peu plus vif mais l'ordre de
-5 et -8 sur les régions d'or les
régions est par contre la nouveauté
c'est une perturbation atlantique qui va
arriver sur la france mercredi par
l'ouest
donnant à redoubler aussi de la neige du
verglas sur bon nombre de régions
surtout la bretagne la normandie l'île
de france les régions ouest
c'est donc cette perturbation située sur
l'atlantique qui va enfin faire reculer
le froid qui nous venaient d'un
anticyclone installé sur l'islande et la
scandinavie ont sevré de à paris 1er de
l'an et faut remonter à 10 79 ans
va-t-elle température la durée au c'est
exceptionnel un ça va faire deux
semaines et demie et l'hiver a commencé
tout le 22 décembre c'est quand même
vraiment aux essais on pense que c'est
exceptionnel météo france
des conditions climatiques qui malgré
tout ne sont pas anormales pour la
france mais statistiquement pour la
prochaine photo de fontaine gelé il
faudra attendre une quinzaine d'années
et puis avoir froid aux pieds
n'empêchera jamais d'avoir le coeur
chaud
après tout tous les moyens sont bons
pour se réchauffer
tout le détail des prévisions de météo
france bien sûr à la fin de cette
édition par sophie davant suite de
l'actualité à l'étranger en algérie
selon les autorités un commando
islamiste a tué seize civils en majorité
des femmes et des enfants lors d'une
attaque la nuit dernière du village de
ben achour au sud d'alger un groupe
d'autodéfense villageois auraient
finalement réussi à repousser les
assaillants
la france déclenché une opération de
guerre contre les soldats centrafricains
en rébellion tenu pour responsable de
l'assassinât samedi de deux militaires
français hélicoptère blindé hommes de
troupes ont été mobilisés de source
française dit mutins ont été tués trente
autres faits prisonniers
un porte parole des rebelles avancent
lui la mort de 32 personnes dont 11
civils
bruno le greffe ce soir le calme règne
sur bangui ces hommes du 6e régiment
parachutiste d'infanterie de marine sont
restés déployés dans la ville
après leur intervention de la nuit une
intervention décidée à paris est défini
comme un geste de légitime défense
l'opération qui a été déclenchée a été
mené en réaction à la président a
délibéré d'un capitaine est de nature en
français par des butins d'autre part
elle a été engagée parce que nous avons
été à nouveau pris à partie par des tirs
de mortiers de part et d'autres venant
des quartiers butin de cabaye et de
péter un peu plus de 2000 soldats
français se trouvent en centrafrique
ce petit pays l'un des plus pauvres au
monde et la plus grande base française
d'afrique après djibouti lié à la france
par un accord de défense conclus en 1960
au lendemain de l'indépendance
la centrafrique est servi de base
arrière aux opérations françaises au
tchad puis au rwanda en avril 96 une
première rébellion provoque une
intervention de la france
il s'agit de protéger les ressortissants
et les intérêts français ainsi que
d'assurer le maintien du président
patassé au pouvoir depuis 1993
depuis deux autres mutineries ont eu
lieu avec toujours la même origine les
soldes ne sont pas versées des
mouvements qui débouche immanquablement
sur des revendications politiques et
finissent par réclamer la démission du
président patassé
le mois dernier quatre chefs d'état
africains avait aidé à la négociation
d'une trêve plus ou moins respecté
elle a connu beaucoup de tension et
d'accrochages à belgrade nouveau succès
les manifestants anti milosevic mais la
forme de la protestation a changé aux
quarante septième jour
c'est désormais en voiture que le régime
est conspué dans un rayon de 5 km le
centre de belgrade était bloqué dans
l'après midi chacun y allant de son
klaxon de sa cloche on de sa panne
supposé proche orient une nouvelle
rencontre entre benyamin nétanyahou et
yasser arafat aurait lieu dans les
prochaines heures selon nos informations
elle pourrait aboutir à la conclusion de
l'accord sur et bron les deux hommes se
sont déjà rencontrés longuement la nuit
dernière aux états unis bill clinton se
réjouit et prend à son compte la baisse
de la criminalité
les crimes graves sont en diminution de
3% aux etats-unis pour le premier
semestre 96
mais ce n'est là qu'une confirmation
d'une tendance qui s'affirme depuis cinq
ans c'est ainsi qu'à new york on passera
en 1996 sous la barre des mille meurtres
l'embauchent de personnel et la
technologie expliquent ce constat
philippe gassot fin de l'année 96
confirme la baisse de la criminalité aux
états unis si on laisse parler les
chiffres
à new york par exemple la baisse du
crime n'a jamais été aussi spectaculaire
plus de 50% de meurtre en moins en six
ans cela fait quand même aujourd'hui
presque mille morts par an soit 20 par
semaine
la principale raison de cette décrue
semble depuis plus d'un an disons le la
peur du gendarme
bill clinton a mis 100 mille policiers
supplémentaires dans la rue à new york
ils sont 7000 de plus soit un total de
près de 40 milles un policier pour 200
habitants de quoi rendre prudents le
mauvais garçon ce succès est dû aux
forces de l'ordre de + l'ordinateur est
devenu superflu et crime vol attaque
tout y est enregistrée en temps réel les
forces de police sont déplacés des zones
calmes sur les points sensibles en
quelques minutes
simple
mais il fallait y penser le petit délit
qu'on laisse faire n'existe plus dès que
la loi est écornée on intervient sortie
des jeunes comme ici après le couvre-feu
voit son bruit la police se montre
sachant que le petit délit peut devenir
grand
le trafic de crack qui entourait une
bonne part du crime s'essouffle d'autant
que les opération quasi militaire se
développe dans ce quartier à haut risque
les policiers ont décidé d'être partout
à la fois les voitures convergent à
n'importe quelle heure il s'agit de
réaliser l'opération saturation dont le
but est de dégoûter les vendeurs de
drogue beaucoup plus calme la pratique
des arts martiaux en chine
un chinois sur deux est un adepte du
tai-chi cette gymnastique lente qui
serait moyen de longévité france 2 à
pékin jérôme baugnies tristan le bref
quand la chine s'éveillera disait
napoléon le monde tremblera
mais depuis deux mille ans déjà les
chinois s'éveille chaque matin à l'heure
où blanchissent les parcs pour entrer en
harmonie avec l'énergie cosmique
leurs sabres ne pour rendre plus les
vagues d'envahisseurs mais prétendent
repousser les ennemis de toujours nage
et la mallette le principe du tai-chi
est simple il s'agit par des gestes
appropriés de laisser circuler l'énergie
interne le tchi les adeptes sont
persuadés que cet art martial est bon
pour la santé
je fais ma santé s'est amélioré mais ma
l'année sont prescrits le tai chi sa
supplie les vaisseaux sanguins
c'est très bon pour la circulation les
spécialistes internationaux des arts
martiaux avaient rendez vous fin octobre
à pékin ce grand maître de mouches ou à
83 ans
certains poussent leur discipline
jusqu'à l'extrême
jan chan restant mur et 1h17 dans la
glace à -2 degrés la température tombe à
33 degrés 6 maintenant j'ai le slip qui
est collée à la glace en tout cas ça
conserve
qui pourrait croire que liane china 39
ans
m douanes a lui aussi trouvé le secret
de la longévité à 89 ans il a encore la
souplesse d'un félin sa recette on franc
je vais rester assis trop longtemps
c'est mauvais pour les reins trop parler
c'est un gâchis d'énergie et oriane ont
regardé nu à l'esprit est trop pensé
c'est mauvais pour la rater
le vieux maître encore de l'énergie à
revendre ils ont distribué aux personnes
et aux objets
il en remplit même les stylos
mais excusez moi celui de l'honorable
correspondant de france 2 est arrivé à
la dernière ligne de son commentaire
économique et social en france avec
depuis le 1er janvier l'établissement de
zones franches dans 44 sites ou
quartiers défavorisés
il s'agit d'y attirer des entrepreneurs
pour une tentative de renouveau social
de ces zones
exemple à champigny sur marne c'est un
boulanger qui s'installe et qui
bénéficiera davantage fiscaux à charge
pour lui de créer des emplois rosen
kerlan bernie mairie ce crépitements si
appétissant on ne l'avait pas entendu
ici depuis bien longtemps
aujourd'hui la boulangerie rooney ne
désemplit pas tout le quartier reprend
goût à la vie c'est le désert complet là
et là je vois que depuis trois jours
qu'on est là ça a vraiment ça ça monte
un petit peu et ça fait vivre les gens
ils sont contents et sans grenade très
bien le pont entre vous suis bien
contente au centre commercial du bois
l'abbé on a décidé de repartir à zéro
l'idée en finir avec les rideaux baissés
les boutiques fermées le moyen la zone
franche et ses avantages fiscaux pour un
tir et chefs d'entreprise et commerçants
la zone franche et son obligation
d'embaucher des personnes du quartier
comme un jour parce que grâce à ce
travail et je suivais chercher mon bas
j'ai vu carlos si je connais depuis
longtemps
je suis obligé d'embaucher 2 3 en plus
parce que c'est une affaire qui marche
c'est pas parce qu'à la zone franche les
gens il faut qu'ils mangent d'ailleurs
les clients en redemande
et ce n'est qu'un début cette année une
supérette va également venir s'installer
on espère que d'autres suivront pour
vendre son âme au quartier sans façon le
commercial a dit rideaux fermés règne un
climat d'insécurité des gens ne veulent
pas rentrer ce qu'un centre commercial
qui a plus de vingt ans d'un véritable
labyrinthe des quoi noir donc les gens
ont peur de rentrer alors que bon il n'y
a pas plus de risques autre part par
contre des rideaux ouverts des enseignes
qui fonctionnent les gens reprennent
confiance et reviennent dans le centre
commercial un espoir pour les quelques
18 mille habitants du bois l'abbé à
toulouse décès de pierre baudis l'ancien
maire udf de la ville avait 80 ans et
souffrait d'un cancer
ce juriste de formation avait occupé des
postes clés la mairie de toulouse de
1959 à 1983 avant que son fils ne lui
succède
on lui apporte d'autres huîtres il se
redresse et se remet aussitôt l ouvrage
avec la même ardeur puis s'effondre
traversé par un spasme plus violent que
les autres cela dure si longtemps qu'on
le croit assoupi on parle ici du dernier
réveillon de françois mitterrand c'était
il ya un an
un an après sa mort l'ancien président
de la république suscite toujours autant
de curiosité et inspire toujours autant
les mémorialistes geneviève moll
philippe jasselin françois mitterrand
aimait ses qui brillait limardo
boulevard baille
il venait d'y chercher des livres rares
mais aussi le parfum de la littérature
en train de se faire il aurait pu
aujourd'hui feuilleter amusé
quelques-uns des 156 livres qui lui sont
au sacré les plus récents ou les
derniers celui de georges marc benamou
par exemple qui souffre sur le dernier
réveillon du jour de l'an 96 à la hâte
au cours duquel françois mitterrand à
manger avec gourmandise une trentaine
des huîtres du foie gras du chapon des
ortolans une argy c'est cet amour de la
vie qui va quitter il veut signifier par
des torrents j de nourriture par cette
discussion politique par ses regards par
son regard sur le ciel et je crois mon
frère c'était très dur comme mais du
rova blement la fin de vie de tout homme
mais que c'est une scène aussi très
belle très forte en tout cas que moi
j'ai vécu émotionnellement très très
fortement comme les gens qui étaient qui
étaient présents ce livre raconte aussi
passionnément les deux dernières années
du vieux chef gaulois atteint par la
maladie et paradis au pouvoir le
portrait les mines de plomb duclos
illustrent le livre d'alain duhamel
un an après la disparition de françois
mitterrand voici le premier bilan
politique mais surtout le portrait
d'ombré de lumière d'un personnage hors
du commun
c'est d'abord un en confiance c'est à
dire que c'est quelqu'un qu'on ne peut
réduire à rien dans aucun domaine
in est univoque il est toujours
ambivalent contradictoires complexe
c'est ce qui le rend passionnant ce qui
le rend irritant si quelquefois ce qui
le rend même exaspérant
cette analyse complète bien celle de
franz olivier giesbert qui a le plus
écrit sur pense à mitterrand 702
casanova un casanova de la politique il
a toujours voulu rester libre vis-à-vis
de pouce vis-à-vis des pouvoirs est
aussi l'audition les patios éteintes les
livres retraçant fin l'itinéraire d'un
homme qui toujours a souffert jusqu'à
serrer les poings du désir de dominer sa
vie
à noter que pierre mauroy déclare sur
europe 1 avoir été informée dès 1980 du
cancer de françois mitterrand qui allait
l'appeler avec verser la tâche de
premier ministre plus contemporain sur
cette même radio robert hue le
secrétaire nationale du parti communiste
a demandé à jacques chirac de prendre
l'initiative d'un référendum sur la
monnaie unique
la page des sports les brivistes ont
battu les gallois de cardiff dans la
deuxième demi finale de la coupe
d'europe de rugby ils rencontreront le
25 janvier prochain en direct sur france
2 les anglais de leicester en finale
florent gautreau une demi finale de
coupe d'europe ça se gagne aussi à coups
de pelles et de pelleteuses toute la
nuit à brive on a balayé déblayer et
personne n'a rechigné
en première ligne les militaires
renforcées pour l'occasion par des
bénévoles qui n'ont pas hésité à braver
le froid au coup d'envoi
la pelouse est dégagé et le quinze
briviste concentré mais timide
heureusement la maison le meilleur
buteur de cette coupe d'europe inscrit
tous les points et la première mi temps
brive mène 9 à 3 à la pause s'en
convainc mais les gallois de cardiff
finaliste l'an dernier vont carrément
craqué en début de deuxième mi-temps
alors brive la ragaillardi s'offrent un
quart d'heure de folie et vendit qui
inscrit le premier essai du match
les gallois dépasser font des fautes et
finissent même le match à quatorze après
l'expulsion de femmes fraises pour une
fois les français ont été les plus sages
sont un petit peu éparpillés sur cette
agressivité ils ont perdu de leur
concentration
al'inverse nous on est restés lucides on
a on savait que de toute façon il ne
servait à rien de répondre à ces petites
chamailleries parce que la même façon on
aurait pu on aurait pu nous aussi à
partir dans tous les sens et met le sens
choisi par les corréziens était le beau
il marquait mais ma deuxième essai grâce
à du bois c'est et l'emportent
finalement 26 à 13
ni la neige ni le froid ni les longs
crampons du capitaine gallois n'auront
eu raison de la volonté de bris dans le
bas car le motard français jean pierre
leduc sur ktm a fait une chute mortelle
dans la deuxième étape de l'épreuve le
duc avait 45 ans c'était sa première
participation à cette compétition on
voit ici dans les derniers instants de
la course
l'étape du jour a été remportée par jean
louis schlesser catégorie autos le
motard peterhansel poursuit lui son
cavalier seul coupe de france de
football les nîmois finaliste l'an
dernier sont éliminé en 32e de finale
par toulouse la mort du dessinateur
belge franquin à 73 ans ce dessinateur
des idées noires avait aussi à son actif
gaston lagaffe le marché plus lanig
modeste et pompon spirou et fantasio au
brier de l'air certains connaissaient
mal andré franquin dessinateur
particulièrement discret mais peut on
oublier son gaston lagaffe l'employé le
plus calamiteux mais l'inventeur le plus
génial de la bande dessinée rallier dès
1945 à la tribu spirou franquin est
d'abord papa d'une créature étrange le
marsupilami
on ne comprend pas très bien ce que
c'est mais les lecteurs en raffolent
pour se distraire franck un passionné de
sciences un coup de génie
il s'appelle gaston lagaffe garçons
feignasses mais l'imagination fertile
franquin un banc alors l'anti héros de
la bd oui je dois petit rebelle ce n'est
pas révolutionnaire
il faut pas
dessinateur dessiner un personnage qui
rit il serait lui-même cet avis elle
c'est la preuve 10 ou le rôle mais qui
fait l'acteur et c'est vrai qu'on près
de 50 ans franquin et gaston avait fini
par se confondre
d'ailleurs il ya tout juste un mois
l'imprévisible lagaf avait décidé de
prendre sa retraite
aujourd'hui c'est son inventeur qui les
fait ses adieux en 1968 il n'y avait pas
que des révolutionnaires la vie continue
et chez les marginaux des banlieues
c'est le thème du premier film du
chanteur compositeur du groupe trust
bernie bonvoisin devenu réalisateur sous
le nom de bernard mon voisin nicole
cornu langlois et marc millet l'ont
rencontrée à sarlat où le film était
présenté en avant première
bon et puis non gitans et nourrit talent
qu'est ce qu'ils deviennent dans tout ça
un conseil si tu leur serrent la main
ont toujours des douanes c'est bien ce
que je dis faut qu'on soit des félins a
déjà vu un léopard changer de rayures de
tâches en les démarches en réalité ses
deux filles de choc surveillent des
voleurs de voitures
deux frères nenê jésus qui traînent leur
adolescence a tardé à coude arnaque et
de frime dans une banlieue plus
politique que réaliste en 1968
une famille d'acteurs s'est déchaînée
pour ce schéma classique deux plans un
drame une vengeance
alors maintenant on va la jouer à la
loyale maintenant il nous faut la page
ira peut-être qu'on craint c'est ça la
loyale ils font ce qu'ils voient oui bah
justement vous allez faire sans nous je
veux pas landreau deux mois on a laissé
passer maintenant déroule écrit sur
mesure par le chanteur compositeur du
groupe trust bernie bonvoisin devenu
auteur réalisateur
j'ai aussi entrepris cette aventure
parce que j'aime les gens j'aime les
mots je ne faisais pas de je n'ai pas de
jets pas de plan de carrière
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de faire les
gens me passionne et donc j'avais envie
d'avoir une espèce de véracité dans tout
ce qu'on a entreprises sur ce projet la
frangine bien bonne
est ce que tu dis bien la voilà
pika s'est laissé pousser les nibards et
y apporte des bonnes feuilles chez les
pays rien à voir
dialogues savoureux aussi entre martin
lamotte et son équipier c'est presque un
poète brio dans un monde de brutes
faut pas me le dire et donc c'est un
personnage qui est à la fois très très
dur bourru comme ça mais mais humain et
ça c'était sympa à faire c'est
l'expérience mois l'action le père de ce
bébé entrée réussie dans le cinéma avec
cette rétro comédie populaire plein
d'audace et de charme
bernie bonvoisin et ses acolytes peuvent
continuer à balad et leur bonne humeur
et leur humour dévastateur
voilà donc pour les démons de jésus dans
quelques instants la météo par sophie
davant 20h50 le salaire de la peur en
version colorisée avec montand et vanel
et puis le dernier journal de la
rédaction de france 2 aux alentours de
minuit par florence dauchez demain 13h
patrick chêne demain 20 heures daniel
bilalian excellente soirée à tous
sur france 2